خلال 2022 شهد المغرب مجموعه من الاحداث
البارزه على الساحه الاجتماعيه والراضيه
نستعرضها معكم في اول فبراير الماضي سقط
الطفل المغربي ريان في بئر العتيق مدينه
شفشاون استمر جهود لانقاذ لخمسه ايام في
تغطيه تابعها الملايين حول العالم لكن
اعلن وفاته كانت فاجعه صدمت الجميع
رياضيات
على مستوى الانديه توج الوداد البيضاوي
بطلنا دوري ابطال افريقيا للمره الثالثه
في تاريخه واحرز نادي نهضه بركان كاس
الاتحاد الافريقي اما على مستوى المنتخب
فحقق اسود الاطلس انجازا غير مسبوق وذلك
بعد تاهوله نصف نهائي كاس العالم كاول
فريق عربي وافريقي يصل هذا الدور واحرازه
المركز الرابع على مستوى الصناعه المغرب
يبدا انتاج اول سياره كهربائيه تابعه
لشركه رينو بمصنع بمدينه طنجه بالاضافه
لاطلاق اول ما السياره محليه خلال يناير
المقبل